- [Helen] This video is
brought to you by Raycon.
(happy music)
- What's up, everybody, Helen here.
It's a pretty good time
to be an adult cartoon.
From the swear-happy South Park.
- Hey, (beep), where's
my mutha (beep) money?
- [Helen] To the constant
flashbacking of Family Guy
- And those guys back at
the factory can suck it.
I'm gonna get outta this place one day.
- [Helen] To the liquor-fueled
antics of Archer and Co.,
many animated shows for grown-ass folks
have become enduring
21st Century classics.
But we'd argue that
possibly the most adult
cartoon of them all
is one, BoJack Horseman.
It's not as profane as South Park,
nor as sexually charged as Archer.
- Because I've swallowed
just about as much
as I can take from you!
- Hey, phrasing!
- [Helen] But in terms of
catapulting it's audience
into a befuddled cloud angsty depression,
the simultaneously hilarious
and gut-wrenching world of
Hollywoo never fails to deliver.
- Look, I gotta go.
- I feel like you didn't
really finish the pep talk.
- I know, but I got a movie
to put together, best of luck.
- [Helen] Part of what
makes BoJack so beloved
is the way it defies convention.
And not just in regards to the ethics of
inter-species romantic love.
The show features frequently depressed
and f'd up characters,
frequently doing pretty
depressing and f'd up things.
Particularly in its later seasons,
the show is less about the lovable antics
of your favorite on-screen pals
than it is an emotionally-trying look
into the lives of severely
flawed and unhappy people.
- Now we just have to solve
the drug crisis in America.
- Easy! We'll take them all.
- Yes!
- [Helen] The most recent half-season
seems to depict an
evolving version of BoJack
fighting his addictions and
becoming a better horse,
along with some smaller, also promising
character arcs for his friends.
But now that the show is
coming to a conclusion,
it has to wrestle with its
fundamental underpinning.
Despite their many attempts,
the characters don't really change.
Understanding why the characters
on BoJack are so static
requires examining the
greater conversation
the show is having with a
familiar form of entertainment.
The comedic sitcom.
We'll explain in this Wisecrack edition on
Change in BoJack Horseman.
Oh, and spoilers ahead
for the show thus far.
But before we get into it,
I wanna give a quick shoutout
to our sponsors over at Raycon.
These wireless headphones are for anyone
who loves music, podcasts, or you know,
just sounds in general.
These little guys create an
immersive audio experience
that's just as amazing as the
other premium brands you know.
But at half the price.
And they come in all sorts
of colors and patterns,
so you can choose the pair
that feels the most you.
To be honest, before I discovered Raycon,
I was kind of a wireless
headphones skeptic.
That's partly because I generally prefer
to spend my money on food
rather than fancy tech stuff.
So, I never saw the point
in shelling out cash
to jump on the wireless
headphone bandwagon
when I could buy like
50 tacos or something
for the same amount.
Plus, I'd never been
able to find any earbuds
to fit my weird ears.
So, I just figured they'd pop out on a run
and be gone forever.
Then, I tried Raycon.
And three months later,
I really don't know how I
went so long without them.
The sound is perfect for
podcasts, music, calls,
you get the idea.
The e25 is Raycon's latest and best model.
It has six hours of playtime,
seamless Bluetooth pairing, and more bass.
Plus, they come in new, fun colors
and a more compact design
that gives you an awesome
noise-isolating fit.
And again, they're around half the price
of the other brands on the market.
So, you can have awesome
headphones and eat your tacos, too.
Go to buyraycon.com/wisecrack,
or click the link in the description below
to get 15% off your order.
Now, back to the show.
Now, let's dive into a
recap of Season 6 so far,
which finds BoJack enduring,
and even semi-thriving in rehab,
where he waters plants,
accidentally gets his
sober horse-doctor drunk,
and speaks unnecessary truths
to the not-powerful
recovering addicts around him.
- Really. Everyone's being honest?
Doug, over here, who keeps
dressing in a suit and tie
even though he's never
getting his finance job back.
(gasps)
- [Helen] Eventually forced
to return to real life,
BoJack finds himself haunted
by the morally bankrupt
horse he used to be.
He embarks on a cross-country
trip to make amends
and figure out what to do with himself,
finally settling, it
seems, on teaching acting
at the hipster-studded liberal
arts college, Wesleyan,
where his half-sister,
Hollyhock, is studying.
However, just when it seems like
BoJack is really becoming a better version
of that vodka-soaked,
self-obsessed celebrity
we've come to know and
yell at in our heads,
something else happens.
Specifically, the eponymous
character doesn't appear at all
in the final episode of this half-season.
Instead, the show focuses entirely
on the victims of his toxic behavior.
From Sarah Lynn, who is super-dead
under mysterious circumstances
currently being investigated
by two hard-nosed reporters,
to Gina, who still has PTSD from the time
BoJack got too into character
and straight up choked her,
to Kelsey, whose career is still suffering
thanks to BoJack's antics.
- If you told me when we were starting out
that one day you'd be
doing chicken commercials--
- Not a commercial.
- [Helen] Worst of all,
this half of the season ends
with Hollyhock just on the precipice
of discovering a horrible truth.
- Who is he?
- [Helen] That when
BoJack was in New Mexico,
he took his ex's daughter, Penny, to prom,
got her friends wasted, and
almost hooked up with her.
Woof.
So, what is the series setting up for
in the final eight episodes?
And what issues should you
expect the show to grapple with?
We have an idea.
But first, we have to talk
about the Big Bang Theory.
It's relevant, we swear.
Now, when Greek philosopher,
Heraclitus of Ephesus, said,
"Change is the only constant in life,"
he clearly couldn't have
predicted the television sitcom.
The sitcom, or a typically family-friendly
comedic television show,
is fundamentally rooted in its characters.
And those characters are generally
rooted in predictability.
As scholar Jason Mittell
argues in his book, Complex TV,
"While it may seem that a
pleasure of serial narratives
"is watching characters
grow and develop over time,
"most television characters
are more stable and consistent
"rather than changeable entities."
He notes that, even in the
face of life-altering events,
characters are more likely
to accumulate experiences
rather to actually learn
and change from them,
the way your Life Coach
suggests you should.
We see this all throughout
the history of sitcoms.
From the self-absorbed Major Frank Burns
on the 70's show, Mash,
to the goofy antics of Kramer,
to the even goofier
antics of Michael Scott.
- Hey, Michael, did you
fall into a koi pond?
- Ah, I can't really hear you.
I think we have sort of a bad connection.
- [Helen] As much as we love
the Sopranos and Mad Men
for their psychological complexity
and deep, ever-evolving characters,
we love plenty of shows
precisely for their
lack of these qualities.
It's because Friends is not the Sopranos
that we want to watch it
at 2pm when we're hungover
or 2am when we can't sleep.
- My life is an embarrassment,
I should just go live
under somebody's stairs.
(laughter)
- [Helen] Minor changes might
occur episode to episode
as the over-arching
plots are driven forward,
the shows themselves remain
fundamentally static.
Marriages, promotions
and other developments
are only skin-deep.
The relationships between the central cast
don't really change, nor do
the characters themselves.
This structure makes them easy to consume.
You can dip in at any point and
know exactly what to expect.
But, more importantly, it blesses
them with the promise that
whatever happens, everything
will have gone back to normal
by the end of the episode.
- Ahhhhhh!
(laughter)
- [Helen] Comfortable,
familiar, always the same.
Usually set in cozy houses, cafes or bars,
these shows keep us nestled
in a comfy status quo
that makes the bitter difficulties
of life feel far away,
for at least 20 minutes or so.
Imagine if Homer Simpson
suddenly didn't want a bite
of that jelly-filled doughnut.
You would probably,
understandably, spiral.
What makes BoJack Horseman
so heart-breaking to watch
is that while the show
maintains the sitcom format
by keeping its characters
on a perpetual emotional hamster wheel,
those characters actually
seem to want to change.
And their inability to do so
is the crux of the
show's painful resonance.
The perfect foil for the
show, BoJack Horseman,
is its delightful meta
show, Horsin' Around,
a series best-described by BoJack himself.
- Look, for a lot of people
life is just one lone,
hard kick in the urethra.
And sometimes, when you
get home from a long day
of getting kicked in the urethra,
you just wanna watch a show about good,
likable people who love each other.
Where, you know, no matter what happens,
at the end of 30 minutes,
everything's gonna turn out okay.
- [Helen] Key to the turning
out okay part is that,
like most sitcoms, nothing really changes.
The characters are monolithic,
simply drawn, and reliably themselves.
In this 90's comedy
evocative of the Cosby Show,
BoJack played the bubbly,
gold-hearted father-figure
to three adorable orphans,
reciting a cheesy platitude
at the end of each episode.
- We're a family now, no matter what,
and I will always be there for you.
- [Helen] The show's
sugary tone of broad humor
and familiar rhythms made
BoJack rich and famous.
But, even 30 years later, he's
still haunted by the question
or whether it was any good.
Still, throughout the series,
BoJack has sought solace
and comfort in Horsin' Around reruns,
which he consumes with an
enthusiasm he typically reserves
only for horse tranquilizers.
Reciting lines, reminiscing over bad jokes
- Nay way, Jose.
(laughs)
- [Helen] And generally
reflecting on what seems to be
the best era of his life.
He appears to long for the simple,
easy emotional connections experienced
by the horse he sees on TV,
even attempting to assume
a good-natured fatherly
role with Sarah Lynn
when she briefly moves
in with him in Season 1,
to disastrously,
metaphorically-incestuous results.
We can pretty much all
relate to BoJack's sentiment.
Life would be easier if
we lived on a static,
happy-family TV show
where everything is
relatively predictable.
But for him, since he
literally was on one,
the contrast becomes all
the more heart-breaking.
Horsin' Around is often
explicitly contrasted
with BoJack's real life,
and that's where things
get really interesting.
Having lived the most significant
years of his existence
on on a sitcom set, BoJack
has come to understand
the utter vapidness of
this inert sitcom world.
- The most important thing is
you gotta give the people what they want.
Even if it kills you,
even if it empties you out
until there's nothing left to empty.
- [Helen] As much as he
longs to return endlessly
to the place in which
nothing ever changes,
he is tormented by the fact that this is,
ironically and tragically,
exactly what his life has become.
He's become a piece of
(beep) who never changes.
Or, perhaps more
precisely, BoJack is living
in an existentially
dreadful shadow of a sitcom.
We can make out as much
from the opening credits of the show,
which, until Season 6, depict
BoJack rising from his bed
in a half-drugged haze.
As he floats, a series
of background images
slowly flash behind him.
The backgrounds change
from season to season,
but the spaced-out,
unreal quality remains,
hinting that he might
continue on this carousel
until the very end.
That's what the characters
in BoJack Horseman do.
They go round and round in
the same interior tracks,
always ending back where they started.
Much like the characters on
Full House or The Brady Bunch,
they same to be fated
to never really change.
- I told you to wait in the car!
(bottle smash)
- [Helen] Despite trying
really, really hard to.
The prime example is BoJack,
who in a nature befitting
a suffering addict,
professes to want to transform
himself and his life,
but never quite succeeds.
In the second season,
BoJack makes a conscious attempt
to overhaul his personality
by plugging into a series
of chipper, metaphor-mixing
self-help tapes.
They don't work because
they're attempts at instantaneous change,
only really served to tinker about
on the surface of a person.
A smile painted sloppily on the
outermost layer of the self.
He takes up running as part
of his self-improvement quest,
but rarely gets far.
At the end of that season's final episode,
he takes to the hill
outside his home once again.
He grunts, complains and
collapses almost immediately,
only to be roused by a voice above him.
- [Macaque] It gets easier.
- Huh?
- [Helen] It's the macaque
who has been quietly jogging
through each episode.
- Every day it gets a little easier.
- Yeah?
- But you've gotta do it every
day. That's the hard part.
But it does get easier.
- Here, the primate seems to voice
the show's perspective on change.
That it's hard and life will kick your ass
as you try to shift your
ingrained behaviors,
but that even the smallest
change can be super rewarding.
Lesson learned, right? Not so fast.
Season 3 returns only to
watch BoJack behave selfishly,
i.e., sleeping with Todd's ex, Emily,
succumb to his addictions,
i.e., going on a pre-AA
bender with Sarah Lynn,
and feel depressed and isolated,
visa vie this incredible
dialogue-free underwater episode.
His inability to change is
perhaps satirized in the episode,
Stop the Presses, in which
BoJack has to leap through hoops
in an attempt to cancel
a newspaper subscription.
As if driving home the point
that, in this universe,
even the most minute,
bureaucratic alteration
is impossible with a capital I-M.
But arguably, the biggest
joke in quotation marks
comes at the end of the season.
BoJack attempts to commit suicide
by forcing his car to crash,
only to change his mind last-minute,
and is promptly rewarded
with the majestic site
of a pack of horses running wild and free.
That's right, he's exactly where he was
at the end of Season 2,
wishing he could run.
This continues for the
next couple of seasons
as BoJack indulges in his vices
and hurts the people he loves,
eventually contributing
to Sarah Lynn's death
in the planetarium after going
on a days' long epic bender with her.
- Right, Sarah Lynn?
Sarah Lynn?
- [Helen] After her funeral,
BoJack reflects on his toxicity
and in one rather on-the-nose moment,
seems to state the show's apparent thesis.
- I don't know how to be, Diane.
Doesn't get better and
it doesn't get easier.
I can't lying to myself
saying that I'm gonna change,
I'm poison.
- [Helen] So much for self-improvement.
Even when you think BoJack could
be getting slightly better,
say, thanks to the influence
of his half-sister, Hollyhock,
he'll be back with a fifth season
centered around his new TV show, Philbert,
in which he'll completely devolve
into an opiate-fueled terror.
The other characters
don't fair much better,
at least in terms of personal development.
Princess Carolyn struggles
with her addiction to work,
difficulty maintaining a relationship,
and then over her desire for a child.
And then her ambivalence
about having a child.
Regardless of the scenario,
she both feels overwhelmed
and doesn't feel like she's doing enough.
She goes from agent to manager,
from girlfriend to single-mom,
from ruthless to empathetic,
but never really changes.
Meanwhile, Diane agonizes
over her integrity.
Whether it's the societal
impact of her girlcroosh videos,
or her role in enabling
BoJack's bad behavior.
The sense that her work and her life
should mean more always haunts her.
She seeks to express herself
creatively with integrity
in a refugee camp, or in
Vietnam, or in writing a memoir.
And yet, each season,
the characters wind up pretty
much back where they began.
Todd is still a man-child,
Mr. Peanutbutter still lives
in mostly blissful ignorance,
and BoJack, even 30 years later,
is still the derelict
horse from Horsin' Around.
(drink spilling)
- When!
- [Helen] Unlike your Cheers!
or I Love Lucy's, though,
there is no comfort in this static state.
There is no peace in
BoJack's tragic flaws.
Because BoJack Horseman shines a light
on the dark crevasses of humanity,
or horse-manity, that sitcoms ignore.
It's characters are simultaneously
deeper and more tragic
than your typical Frasier affair.
The repetitive nature of
each character's story
feels less like the fun-loving
antics of All In The Family
and more like the actual living-nightmare
of a human being trying
to change in real life.
- That's too much, man!
(laughter)
- The unchanging nature
of things in Hollywoo
becomes a torturous existential trap,
a bitter and continual
reminder of the fact that
real life is kina the same.
No matter what happens today,
you'll wake up the same person tomorrow.
No promotion, no marriage,
no big symbolic change
will take you away from who you are.
So, BoJack's effectively stuck, right?
Not quite.
The show isn't simply content to teach us
that people can't change no
matter how hard they try,
Season 6 thus far feels
more devastating than that.
Rather than dark sitcom-like repetition,
the eight episodes witness BoJack
actually seeming to evolve
in a meaningful way,
albeit slowly and painfully.
Still imperfect, he enables
teenage rehab resident Jameson
to behave badly and act out,
much as he did with Sarah Lynn.
But, even when he messes up, he's trying.
Yes, he keeps vodka around
because he thinks he's special
and can withstand his addiction.
And yes, that vodka accidentally
gets doctor horse drunk.
But he stays with said horse doctor
and repeatedly tries to
get him back on the wagon.
You know, progress.
Plus, he urges Diane to get on meds,
tries to find Todd an asexual partner,
and he even brings Princess
Carolyn's baby a present.
Though, it naturally is
a portrait of himself
as a narcissist.
Hell, he even gives Mr.
Peanutbutter a crossover episode.
And by the end of the eight episode,
other characters seem to be
making small changes, too.
Diane goes on antidepressants,
Princess Carolyn seems
to reset her priorities,
Todd realizes his
perpetual childlike nature
makes him an excellent manny,
and Mr. Peanutbutter attempts
to atone for his infidelity.
These changes are small,
maybe even microscopic,
but they're there.
Every inch of change has been hard-won.
Is something meaningful happening? Maybe.
And it feels most profound in episode 7,
when BoJack travels the country
visiting some of the people
he's hurt or alienated.
He apologizes, tries to make things right,
and genuinely seems to
atone for who he is.
He appears to ditch
some of the superficial
trappings of his persona,
allowing his hair to gray as he reconciles
with his former hairdresser
who he got fired from Horsin' Around.
He even tries to get over
his life-long aversion to other horses.
And then, episode 8.
Episode 8 is so depressing
because it reminds us of
the BoJack we used to know.
Before the extensive horse
therapy and the apologies.
Before the even vague sense of decency
or the desire to be a
role model for Hollyhock.
We're forced to remember
every mistake he made
and the long list of
victims left in the wake
of his pathological selfishness.
And we're left wondering
will the changes BoJack
has made even matter?
Is there a point in your life
when you've hurt enough people
that your own personal
evolution becomes irrelevant?
BoJack's journey has been
one of the most emotional
of any animated TV protagonist.
And yet, it's paved entirely with the hurt
and damaged souls, mostly women,
he's injured along the way.
While the show may be indicating
that BoJack has finally changed,
it also suggests that he
may have caused more damage
than even the most throughout
evolution could excuse.
So, what does it all mean?
Well, we think that the
writers of BoJack Horseman
have always situated Horsin' Around
as the imperfect mirror image
to the actual show they're creating.
Horsin' Around may be
comforting in its platitudes,
but it's also disingenuous.
Nobody gets horribly hurt,
and nobody's particularly deep or honest.
On BoJack, it's the opposite.
Everybody is hurting, often horribly.
And the characters are often deep
and quite honest about their pain.
- [Hollyhock] But it wasn't all bad.
I mean, yeah I got secretly
drugged for months on end
to the point where I
was living a nightmare
in which I couldn't recognize my own body
or understand what was
happening to my brain, but
other than that it was a
pretty chill experience.
- I should've protected you.
I really wanted to be a
good day to you, Hollyhock.
- Well, turns out your not my dad at all.
- Yeah, good thing, I guess.
- [Helen] The stasis that makes shows
like Hosin' Around comforting
makes BoJack brilliant,
and sometimes borderline
intolerable to watch.
And we have literally no idea
what's gonna happen next.
Sorry.
But, what do you guys think?
Is BoJack beyond redemption?
Is changing oneself
essentially impossible?
And if so, should any of us
really bother to be better?
Let us know what you
think in the comments.
Thanks to all our dope patrons
for supporting our channel and podcast.
Pretty please hit that Subscribe
button, and before you go,
I just want to give another shoutout
to our sponsors at Raycon.
These wireless headphones
have audio as awesome and
noise-isolating as any other
premium brands on the market.
Go to buyraycon.com/wisecrack
or click the link in the description below
to get 15% off your order.
And that's all I got.
Thanks for watching guys.
Peace.
(upbeat music)